desde la cepal el organismo del cual
usted hace parte reportaron que al menos
4000 91 mujeres fueron víctimas de
feminicidios en el año 2020 esto en
américa latina y el caribe y la mayor
visibilidad y condena social no detiene
este flagelo porque
así es buenas noches buenas tardes
santiago un saludo a france 24 la
violencia de género no es un hecho
aislado
es persistente no conoce fronteras
afecta tú has dicho una de cada tres
mujeres sufre violencia por parte de su
pareja o expareja y dos de cada tres en
algún momento de su vida en el espacio
público en el trabajo en la
participación política en la escuela en
fin es lo que hemos llamado en la onu
una pandemia a la sombra impacta la
salud la libertad la seguridad y además
la expresión extrema de la
discriminación y desigualdad
estamos viendo en esta pandemia como las
mujeres han sido las más afectadas por
la pérdida de empleo la sobrecarga del
trabajo no remunerado la pobreza
entonces autonomía económica
autonomía política y autonomía en la
toma de decisiones y una vida libre de
violencia este es el continuo que
estamos trabajando la cepal mide dos
indicadores y consolida lo que nos dicen
los gobiernos cada año feminicidio que
es la expresión más violenta de la
violencia y matrimonio infantil que es
el otro indicador que miramos y que es
una práctica nociva que afecta a las
niñas
ahora américa latina es una región
bastante heterogénea donde encuentra
usted las situaciones más críticas y por
el contrario que avances podría destacar
si es que los hay en alguna región
hay situaciones críticas como le digo es
una región donde el machismo mata por
eso me gusta lo que ustedes están
proyectando hoy millones de mujeres y
hombres están saliendo a la calle para
decir basta ya ni una menos vivas nos
queremos entonces la sociedad se está
movilizando la condena social es mayor
de hecho tengo que decir que hoy día
conmemoramos ya esta es una propuesta
que vino de américa latina' en el primer
encuentro feminista que ocurrió allí en
bogotá hace 40 años
para conmemorar a visibilizar el
asesinato de las hermanas mirabal patria
minerva y maría teresa en república
dominicana por la dictadura de trujillo
luego la onu toma este día y hoy es un
día que se conmemora en todo el día para
visibilizar el problema y las soluciones
hay soluciones hay sabemos lo que hay
que hacer sabemos esta es una región que
tiene una convención específica la
convención de belén do pará es una
región que en las constituciones de
nuestros países se habla de igualdad y
no discriminación
acaba de aprobarse entrar en vigor hoy
un convenio que es clave que es el
escaso el convenio de escazú que protege
a las defensoras de derechos humanos
especialmente las defensoras ambientales
por ejemplo y ya tenemos 17 países que
han tipificado feminicidio y que están
haciendo leyes integrales entonces hay
avances sobre todo en el ámbito
normativo pero cuando vemos estos datos
realmente es inaceptable o sea creo que
lo que hoy día la sociedad
latinoamericana está saliendo a decir es
que esta situación de pandemia ya no
puede seguir en silencio no puede seguir
en impunidad y necesitamos por eso nos
hemos pintado de naranja aquí en la teja
de la cepal estamos llamando a todo el
mundo a pintar el mundo de naranja para
poner la idea de tu mundo libre de
violencia y libre de discriminación es
posible ahora hablaba usted de ni una
menos cree usted que este movimiento
marcó un antes y un después
por supuesto que sí porque
de un mensaje muy potente primero a las
sobrevivientes ya las mujeres que están
sufriendo violencia
salimos arroparlas de decir no están
solas las honramos a ustedes a sus
movimientos a sus familias no
dignificamos a las mujeres porque no
olvidemos que muchas veces la violencia
y el control sobre sobre los cuerpos de
las mujeres lo que hemos llamado esta
cultura del patriarcado se basa
efectivamente en el control en el poder
en la violencia en la discriminación a
estos movimientos deben y una menos
están sumando como dio cada vez más
hombres que están buscando bajarse de
esa cultura violenta y machista que
también les daña a ellos tanto es claro
empezó en juárez empezó en méxico de ahí
siguió argentina a chile a uruguay y hoy
día ustedes lo han mostrado toda américa
latina está sumando una voz
para no dejar a nadie atrás y
efectivamente poner fin a esta pandemia